بالعوده الى البيت الذي كانت يعني يعبره
بردا
لحفز مخيلات كثيره في الشعر وفي الرسم هذا
النهر رغم انه جف الان للاسف يعني شو مصير
هذا البيت الان يعني مجهول يعني افضل
ابتعد عن القصه عن هذا الموضوع لانه يشكل
الي جرح لانه فجاه تفقد بيت بمثابه مملكه
تصور بدمش كان كنت لا اضطر اخرج الى
المدينه ياتيني يعني
ليس المكان فحسب روح المكان وطاقات المكان
عمره ممكن سنه بدايه الفتره العثمانيه
وبعد ذلك تم توارثه عن طريق العوائل
الدمشقيه لكن مثلا احيانا يصور في افلام
او مسلسلات البيت لكن البيت
كنقطه يعني اشاعه ثقافي كان مهم جدا يعني
كنا نقيم فيه سهرات فنيه ونقيم فيه مثل
المعارض ورش عمل يعني هذا بشكل لك جرح هذا
الانسلاخ عنه امانه امانه هذا لا ازال
اعيش من هذه الزواده وليس من العالم اللي
طفت يعني 90% من العالمين اتمنى ان ارجع
يوما ما الى سوريا لن تبقى بالنسبه لي
يعني هي الملهمه الاولى